[Music]
people we'd unknown to risk their lives
strong man and strong us alone never
heard that
it's not saying that's the opposite of
what the saying is if you guys could
tweak one thing about your costume what
would it be
start with gets a little hotter
yeah they were the sorbonne I will make
the corset like more comfortable and I'd
lose the the wedges I would make and we
will do this as a matter of fact the
little strings a little cords that
connect the different parts of the suit
I would make them a little more durable
make them out of a more durable material
because they would break a lot
oh really we were doing stunt work and
running just fall off no they were just
sometimes yeah it was crazy then
suddenly I had hair like Jason was going
behind my head I had Henry's cape and it
was just picture me doing that how about
you cyborg you know what I probably
actually have a costume I'm all CG this
I will say it was probably the most
probably the most comfortable costume
outside of the eyepiece I actually which
it actually would change that piece a
little smaller it's just it just took
away the attention from everything else
you could definitely catch been just
over with just lock onto a nobody I know
[Music]
you